[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour cette
huitième journée de débat sur la réforme
des retraites ici au Sénat les équipes
de Public Sénat restent mobilisées pour
vous faire vivre ses échanges toute la
journée et toute la soirée en direct sur
notre antenne et aussi sur notre site
internet public sénat.fr vous serez
aussi également directe de la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat avec Steve Jourdain
qui va commenter ses débats on le
rappelle l'information de la soirée
d'hier c'est que le Sénat a enfin voté
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans article essentiel de
cette réforme des retraites et ce matin
allez débats vont être directement très
intéressant très important puisque les
sénateurs vont discuter de l'amendement
du président du groupe les républicains
anciennes à Bruno retaillaux qui veut
accélérer la suppression des régimes
spéciaux qui est prévu par cette réforme
des retraites une réforme de retraite
qui contient la clause du grand-père
c'est à dire que seulement elle est
salarié entrant dans les entreprises
concernées par ces régimes spéciaux
seront concernés par leur suppression et
Bruno Retailleau veut supprimer cette
clause du grand-père alors on entend que
les débats commencent véritablement sur
ces régimes spéciaux on va peut-être
rejoindre Steve Jourdain en tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve le Sénat au
théière enfin à cet article 7 mais les
débats ont été tendus oui Alex 15 heures
de débat 15h et bien de galipette
procédure à 15h de débat très mouvementé
au terme desquels effectivement
l'article 7 a été adopté le Sénat qui a
donc donné son feu vert à la retraite à
64 ans 15 heures de débat qu'on a pu
suivre en direct en intégralité sur
Public Sénat et au cours desquelles et
ben on a découvert certains trésors de
la procédure législative avec notamment
l'utilisation de cet article 38 et bien
du Règlement du Sénat cet article qui
permet de limiter le temps de parole par
article ou par amendement il a été
dégainé par la droite qui souhaite
accélérer l'examen de cette réforme qui
souhaite et bien que ce projet loi soit
adopté d'ici à dimanche soir la gauche
évidemment si est opposée on verra si
cet article sera à nouveau dégainé dans
les prochaines heures alors sur cet
article 7 Alex l'hémicycle se divise
c'est divisé au moment du vote un peu
schématiquement en deux avec sans
surprise une droite qui a très largement
voté en faveur de la retraite à 64 ans
sur 145 votants seuls 2 seul 2 sénateurs
LR ont voté contre et de l'autre côté de
l'hémicier qui avait la gauche à voter
comme un seul homme contre la retraite à
64 ans la gauche qui est composée de
trois groupes les écologistes les
socialistes et les communistes place
maintenant vous l'avez dit à aux
articles qui suivent donc l'article
c'est très article sont encore à
examiner d'ici à dimanche on va suivre
notamment l'amendement de Bruno
Retailleau que vous avez évoqué Alex cet
amendement qui prévoit une 10 à
disparition des régimes spéciaux une
disparition que la droite veut plus
rapide que le gouvernement la séance a
donc s'annonce donc très mouvementée on
va suivre ça bien sûr en direct sur
Public Sénat merci beaucoup Steve allez
à la direction l'hémicycle du Sénat pour
la suite des débats sur la réforme des
retraites
de règlement du Sénat je demande
monsieur le Président la réserve de
l'examen de
l'amendement 2057 après l'article 13
selon l'article 44 alinéa 6 du règlement
la réserve est de droit quand elle est
demandée par la Commission saisie au
fond ce qui vient d'être le cas sauf
opposition du gouvernement avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente de la Commission madame et
monsieur le rapporteur Madame et
Monsieur les sénateurs j'ai dit de
manière systématique depuis le début de
votre travaux et de nos débats le
gouvernement ne s'oppose jamais à la
Commission pour ce qui concerne les
questions de recevabilité d'y
recevoiralité ou d'organisation des
débats donc la vie est bien évidemment
favorable
la réserve est donc ordonnée
et donc chers collègues
la discussion des amendements va
reprendre
au niveau de l'amendement numéro 608
rectifié bis de Madame qu'on cogne si je
peux terminer ma phrase cher collègue
[Musique]
pardon mais l'ordre des débats un courbe
à la présidence quel que soit celui qui
l'exerce
donc la discussion reprendra à
l'amendement 608 si vous voulez bien
vous y reporter et s'il y a une
un rappel au règlement il est le
bienvenu
monsieur le Président kaner
merci monsieur le Président mais je vous
rassure je n'étais pas irrespectueux à
l'égard de votre responsabilité je vous
laisse vérifier que vous avez bien vu
mon rappel au Règlement
sur la base de l'article 44 bis
concernant le droit d'amendement des
parlementaires
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons vu quand même au travers de
cette réserve alors que nous préparions
tous à batailler à ferrailler
naturellement sur un amendement qui est
très important d'ailleurs nous voulions
voir aborder plutôt dans le débat
parlementaire notamment sur la partie
recette
et voilà par surprise je ne dirais pas
des Loyauté ce serait trop fort mais par
surprise alors que Monsieur Retailleau
hier nous a fait une très grande
diatribe en disant vous les obstructeurs
je résume et bien vous utilisez
vous utilisez les arguties pour ne pas
aller au débat ce matin je tiens à le
dire nous étions prêts nous étions prêts
à ferrailler monsieur le Président du
Groupe LR et aujourd'hui vous décalez
votre intervention je trouve cela
vraiment extrêmement déloyale
regard du bon déroulement de nos travaux
et la sincérité de nos débats est
toujours très importante y compris par
rapport à d'éventuelles recours devant
le Conseil constitutionnel donc nous
sommes prêts je vous rassure même après
l'article 13 nous faire haïrons contre
cette amendement amendement qui est
totalement inique injuste notamment pour
les travailleurs de ces entreprises qui
vont être supprimées en termes de
retraite merci à vous
très bien monsieur le Président
Retailleau pour un autre rappel au
Règlement sur le même fondement que
celui qu'a utilisé mon collègue
président du groupe bien sûr que nous
allons discuter de la normand que j'ai
déposé simplement je voudrais porter à
votre connaissance chers collègues que
au moment où je vous parle hier c'était
le président Larcher
dans la permanence était privilégicité
et ceux qui ont fait cela et ceux qui
ont fait cela et ceux qui ont fait cela
ont aussi coupé l'électricité d'une
clinique au moment où je vous parle
d'autres sénateurs ont vu à l'heure
domicile à leur entreprise l'électricité
coupée au moment où je vous parle
j'attends je n'accuse personne
mes chers collègues
écoutez-moi bien mes chers collègues
gardez votre calme
j'attends de la gauche qu'elle dénonce
aussi uneanimement ces agissements
uneanimement ce sont des violences qui
sont faites à des élus de la République
et il y a là comme une appropriation
partisanée personnelle des moyens de
production d'énergie qui appartiennent
au peuples français et non pas à tel ou
tel Corporation
[Applaudissements]
madame Brulin à la parole pour un rappel
au règlement
merci monsieur le président
dré interroger nos collègues des
républicains avez-vous la réforme et
votre soutien au gouvernement honteux ce
matin vous avez multiplié les procédures
pour que l'article 7 soit voté en pleine
nuit
il s'en est fallu de deux nuits pour
qu'il soit adopté et aujourd'hui vous
voulez retarder l'examen d'un article
qui suscite beaucoup de colère dans
notre pays ce que vous avez évoqué
monsieur Retailleau témoigne précisément
de la colère que suscite votre
amendement et vous voulez l'examiner
loin du regard de nos concitoyens qui
sont les premiers concernés
je
considère que cet amendement doit être
discuté en plein jour ainsi que les sous
amendements que nous avons déposés parce
que voyez-vous
ce dont nous parlons ça n'est pas
d'obstruction ou de sous amendements que
vous considérez
inutile c'est de regarder concrètement
précisément métier par métier ce que
votre amendement va induire pour des
travailleurs dont les conditions de
travail sont extrêmement difficiles je
pense que monsieur le Président il
faudrait faire une suspension de séances
pour que chaque groupe puisse
réorganiser son travail à partir de ce
qui vient d'être proposé et je pense que
le report de l'examen de l'amendement du
président retaillau doit permettre à la
commission des affaires sociales
d'examiner de manière approfondie c'est
sous amendement ce qui n'a pour
l'instant pas été le cas sur les sous
amendements déposés par les groupes de
gauche ces dernières heures
monsieur le Président Gontard a la
parole pour un autre et pensons-nous
ultime rappel au règlement merci
monsieur le Président sur l'article 38 à
Ina 8 d'abord pour rappeler quand même
que le rappel au règlement de du
président Retailleau était totalement
hors sujet qu'on n'est pas là pour non
il était totalement hors sujet par
rapport à ce qui est en train de se
passer deuxièmement par rapport à cet
amendement moi je rappelle quand même
que hier soir on a arrêté la séance
prématurément parce qu'il restait du
temps parce que je crois que Monsieur
Retailleau était déjà parti donc on a
cru comprendre qu'on a arrêté la séance
pour pouvoir examiner l'amendement de
Monsieur Retailleau et puis on arrive ce
matin et puis on s'aperçoit que cet
amendement du coup on le repousse
de quoi avez-vous peur pourquoi cette
désertion
parlons-en parlons-en c'est un sujet
important on est d'accord parlons-en
remettez-le et qu'on puisse discuter
dans le fond depuis le début vous
refusez de le débat vous refusez
discuter vous nous avez corseté vous
nous avez enfermé dans un débat je
dirais à sens unique et vous continuez
vous continuez comme ça
franchement un peu de courage remettez
cette amendement qu'on puisse débattre
tranquillement merci
la parole est à monsieur n'est pas le
Savary
oui je crois que
ce débat sur la retraite mérite
véritablement
que nous soyons attentifs
par rapport aux autres
en conséquence mes chers collègues
vous avez sacrifié me semble-t-il à
travers votre volonté d'obstruction
disons-le de présenter de présenter des
amendements pour lequel l'objet n'était
pas d'une
qualité à la hauteur de nos débats me
semble-t-il et qui ne correspondait pas
surtout à vos interventions vous savez
souhaité depuis des heures et des heures
manifester votre hostilité à cette
réforme on l'a bien compris mais pendant
ce temps-là nous n'avons pas nous
n'avons pas entamé le débat de fond et
maintenant vous reprochez vous reprochez
que nous soyons en retard par rapport à
ce débat alors réfléchissez bien il vous
appartient d'être attentif de pas
forcément mettre des sous amendements
par rapport aux amendements que nous
proposons et qui va encore retarder le
débat c'est la raison pour laquelle je
ne vous invite mes chers collègues à
être attentif à tout cela et bien
réfléchir que nous avons véritablement
des sujets importants qui méritent
encore des heures de discussion et nous
souhaitons vivement aborder cette
discussion merci
donc nous allons ouvrir la discussion
sur l'amendement 608 est-ce que monsieur
Lurel peut le présenter puisqu'ils le
seul signataire présent
l'amendement 608
il y a déjà eu des il y a déjà eu des
réparations
madame la Présidente
doit votre président et tout en
admettant bien volontiers que c'est vous
qui présidez personne d'autre néanmoins
l'article 36 précise que la parole est
accordée sur le champ à tous sénateurs
qui la demande pour un rappel au
règlement l'auteur doit simplement faire
référence à un article du règlement donc
je vous invite monsieur le Président a
appliquer cet article 36 alinéa 3 et a
donné la parole au collègue qu'il la
demande pour des rappels au règlement
qu'il a de bon
je ne vous avais pas vu et donc ça
aurait été plus simple merci monsieur je
vais vous citer évidemment très
précisément l'article auquel je fais
référence et l'article 33 qui traite
notamment des attaques enfin du
comportement dans l'hémicycle le
président Bruno Retailleau a rapporté
des faits extérieurs à notre hémicycle
mais les a rapportés en s'adressant
manifestement directement au président
kaner nous nous bataillons fermement
contre cette réforme nous utilisons ce
des outils que le règlement nous accorde
nous l'opposition mais nous ne sommes en
aucune manière responsable des faits
tout à fait regrettable et parfois
délictueux que le président Retailleau a
rapporté et parfois des luxueux que le
président Retailleau a rapporté il
serait bon que ces attaques personnelles
qui sont proscrites par l'article 33 de
notre règlement n'est pas lieu dans
cette hémicycle vous portez une réforme
nous l'avons compris vous l'avez conçu
cette réforme vous l'avez confiée au
gouvernement c'est un peu une gestation
pour autrui que vous avez fait une
gestation pour le gouvernement
accouchement et un peu difficile nous en
convenons retrouvons notre calme c'est
son ces attaques et appliquons les
articles de notre règlement je vous
remercie
c'est donc ce que nous allons pouvoir
faire quel est l'orateur qui veut
défendre l'amendement numéro 608
rectifié vis
Madame A poursuppoli
merci monsieur le président
se rappelle au règlement
ce 44 bis ma collègue colline Brunin
vient de vous demander une suspension de
séance je crois que ça serait normal de
nous l'accorder parce que l'amendement
de Monsieur Retailleau devait venir hier
soir il n'est pas arrivé il venait il
devait venir ce matin il n'est toujours
pas là et maintenant monsieur Retailleau
nous propose donc de discuter en
catimini ce soir de cet amendement et
donc ce n'est pas possible nous vous le
disons depuis le début nous ne faisons
pas d'obstruction nous défendons pieds à
pied la réforme des retraites
c'est vous qui êtes l'obstruction
l'obstruction au peuple l'obstruction
aux gens qui défilent dans la rue et qui
combattent votre réforme et c'est pour
ça que cette nuit vous nous avez fait
voter en catimini l'article 7 parce que
vous êtes vous avez honte finalement de
ce que vous êtes en train de faire alors
on a on a eu le tour Monsieur
nos amendements finalement n'ont pas été
n'ont pas été la fois passée ils n'ont
pas ils ne sont pas venus en commission
des affaires sociales c'était un
simulacre démocratie alors nous
demandons de réunir la commission des
affaires sociales que Monsieur
Retailleau puisse déposer son amendement
comme c'était prévu ce matin dans
l'ordre du jour que nous puissions
réunir la commission des affaires
sociales pour discuter de nos
sous-amendements
pour un rappel au règlement je suppose
oui merci monsieur le Président rappelle
le Règlement sur les mêmes fondements et
en réaction à ma collègue à poursu poli
j'entends bien ça demande de
d'arrêt pour quelques minutes pour
réorganiser son travail je sais mais
qu'il se pose la même question en posant
en autant d'amendements en catimini
cette nuit pour les autres groupes qui
ne les découvrent ce matin et et je
rappelle je rappelle que l'hypocrisie a
été soulevée élevée hier sur les
discussions qu'il y a pu avoir en
réunion des présidents où il est très
clair que l'obstruction a été clairement
annoncé ici et que donc vous devez
l'assumer maintenant ça sera beaucoup
plus simple et ça nous évitera de perdre
un temps fou donc moi je maintiens je
suis désolé que nous mon contenu aux
travaux et que travailler la nuit fait
partie de notre mission et qu'il est
étonnant que vous parliez de Catimini
quand on nous travaillons la nuit c'est
notre rôle à tous il n'y a aucun
changement d'un vote de nuit comme d'un
vote de jour ou alors demander que les
séances s'arrêtent à 6h du soir comme de
bon de bonnes personnes qui doivent
travailler la nuit merci toujours pour
la commission
monsieur le rapporteur la commission est
disponible jour et nuit mais Cathy
apporte aux poly
vous avez une volonté d'opposition
d'accord mais ceux qui ont la volonté de
débattre les Français l'attendent
permettaient quand même que le Parlement
puisse jouer son rôle en conséquence
réviser vos arguments d'opposition quand
même au moins qu'il tienne au moins
qu'ils tiennent ils ne tiennent pas donc
soyez attentif à cela quand même nous
n'avons jamais eu l'habitude de
travailler comme ça il y a toujours eu
un respect dans le bail bad
confrontation qui est nécessaire au
Parlement
convenait en donc ressaisissez-vous et
faites en sorte qu'on puisse enfin
débattre
[Applaudissements]
le rapporteur s'est exprimé avec la
sentiment de la présidente de la
commission
ce qui conduit donc à ce que nous
poursuivions le débat et Monsieur Durin
est appelé et conviés à bien vouloir
présenter l'amendement 608 rectif les
vis dont il est le signataire après bien
entendu que Madame ponce nous aurait
éclairé sur son interprétation du
règlement
et bien monsieur le Président votre
phrase être productive est totalement
dans l'objet de mon intervention
parce que je suis une sénatrice récente
mais après les
retours
rappelle au règlement de Monsieur
Retailleau et de Monsieur lévrier
vraiment pour moi c'est complètement
sans objet je compte alors donc
effectivement c'est plutôt moi qui
demande à être éclairé je comprends que
Monsieur retaillé le matin
des 10h30 et besoin de sa dose
idéologique son discours il y en a qui
prennent de la vitamine C oui il y en a
qui prennent de la vitamine C vous vous
avez besoin de vous injecter des doses
idéologiques très tôt le matin pour vous
donner de la force très bien mais oui
mais en quoi les coupures d'électricité
en quoi les coupures d'électricité
étaient un objet du rappel au règlement
vous me l'expliquerez et puis arrêtez de
dire qu'on veut pas aller au débat de
fond
le débat de fond c'était hier c'était
l'article 7 que vous avez restreint
effectivement parce qu'effectivement si
je suis le maillot jaune vous n'étiez
pas dans le peloton et donc et donc oui
le débat de fond nous le voulions les
syndicats le voulaient on avait 5 jours
il voulait bien qu'on passe au moins
deux jours sur l'article 7 mais vous ça
vous intéressez pas ce qui vous
intéresse c'est les autres articles
c'est de montrer qu'il y a quelques
mesures d'accompagnement voilà
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi un rappel au
règlement que celui de me dire
merci Madame maintenant la parole est à
Monsieur Durin sur l'amendement 608
rectifié bis
monsieur le président
le projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale qui
porte réforme du système de retraite ne
contient à ce stade aucune mesure
spécifique concernant l'adite outre-mer
pourtant notre situation est très
différente notre situation je parle au
nom des collègues qui ont déposé
l'amendement de celle de l'Hexagone en
raison de l'arrivée tardive de la
sécurité sociale dans nos territoires et
de la persistance tiers à notre histoire
d'une part importante de travail un
formel ou de défauts de déclaration les
carrières hachées sont de ce fait sur
représentés dans les outre-mer et très
difficile à reconstituer faute
d’archives complètes il en ressort un
niveau de pension de base sensiblement
plus bas que dans l'Hexagone et un
nombre très important de retrait pauvre
voire très pauvre les données repères de
la sécurité sociale nous donne à ce
titre des chiffres éclairants l'âge
moyen du départ à la retraite en
Martinique et de 65,3 ans contre 62,9
ans au niveau national en raison d'un
nombre de trimestres validés plus
difficiles à atteindre pour les
Martiniquais cela confirmé par une étude
menée sur la génération 61-64 par la
Sécurité Sociale
6,5% des assurés de cette génération
sont partis à la retraite au niveau
national contre moins de 1% en
Martinique un peu plus de 6% des assurés
de cette génération sont concernés par
des trous de carrière en France contre
20% Martinique les validités incomplètes
sont largement supérieures en Martinique
concernant les départs anticipés là
aussi des différences sur notables il
concerne 2% des assureurs en Martinique
en 2020 1% en Guadeloupe 3% en Guyane et
à la Réunion quand il concerne 20% des
assurés au niveau national
l'accélération du passage à 43 annuités
de cotisations viendra renforcer la
difficulté pour les habitants de ladite
outre-mer dans les années 60 à atteindre
le nombre de trimestres requis pour
bénéficier d'une pension complète cela
les contre-indra donc à travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans l'âge du taux plein
l'article 40 de la Constitution ne nous
permet pas de sortir les collectivités
d'outre-mer de l'application de ce
nouveau calendrier à défaut c'est
amendement demande un rapport au
gouvernement sur les conséquences de
l'accélération de l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation dans les outre-mer
merci chers collègues et maintenant nous
avons à nous prononcer enfin nous avons
examiné une série de sous amendements
qui commencent par le 4000
rebondissement dans l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites au Sénat le
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno retailleux devait défendre ce
matin un amendement qui accélère la
suppression des régimes spéciaux de
retraite de certains régimes spéciaux de
retraite qui est prévu par ce
gouvernement et finalement et bien cet
amendement a été reporté plus tard dans
le texte de cette réforme de retraite on
va retrouver Steve Jourdain qui a suivi
ses échanges tendus ce matin dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat à Steve
racontez-nous un peu ce nouveau
rebondissement oui c'est ce qui
s'appelle démarrer pied au plancher Alex
vous l'avez dit on était censé reprendre
l'examen de cette réforme des retraites
avec cet amendement de Bruno Roteo qui
prévoit effectivement d'accélérer la
suppression des régimes spéciaux elle
est plus vite en quelque sorte que ce
que veut le gouvernement finalement
la commission des affaires sociales a
demandé à ce que cet amendement soit
examiné plus tard c'est-à-dire après
l'article 13 qu'on comprend aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle et bien c'est que on
assiste on reprend sur un tempo de
guérilla parlementaire avec une droite
qui veut aller très vite qui veut que
cette réforme soit examinée d'ici à
dimanche minuit c'est la deadline qui
est fixée par le gouvernement et une
gauche qui va tenter bien de ralentir
les débats Voir d'empêcher et bien à ce
que cette réforme à ce que ce projet de
loi soit voté dans l'ensemble donc ce
dimanche il reste quelques jours
d'examen et ça promet on le voit
aujourd'hui d'être encore très
mouvementée Alex merci beaucoup Steve
avant de réagir à ce nouveau
rebondissement avec le sénateur
socialiste Rémi Cardon on va faire un
nouveau détour par la séance de
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour voir ce qu'il
passe ce qu'il se passe
d'accord on n'avait pas le même devant
nous comme quoi vous voyez nous non plus
nous n'avons pas toujours les mêmes
éléments
bon mais en réalité monsieur le
Président canner les masques sont tombés
vous faites de l'obstruction ce rapport
c'est sous amendements c'est
effectivement quand même de
l'obstruction
donc
je consulte le gouvernement sur cet
amendement 608
défavorable explication de vote monsieur
jaumier et ensuite de Madame meunier
monsieur jaumier c'est à vous
ah le ministre a été tellement
synthétique que je n'ai pas entendu
excusez-moi
c'est ta maman qui est important puisque
il porte effectivement sur la question
de nos collègues des départements
ultramarins qui présente comme c'est
exposé expliqué dans l'exposé des motifs
je fais pas le relire mais des
caractéristiques de carrière qui sont
bien différents et d'état de santé aussi
qui sont bien différents et
d'indicateurs d'espérance de vie en
bonne santé qui sont également très
différents et pas dans un sens favorable
donc cette question n'a pas été traitée
n'est pas traitée en fait dans ce projet
de loi ça a été soulevé par Victorin
Lurel de façon très forte hier ou
avant-hier dans le débat la non prise en
compte de ces particularités dans ce
projet de loi et donc la demande de ce
rapport sur les conséquences de
l'application des dispositions prévues
nous paraît tout à fait importante je
pense que c'est un message qu'on pas
porter envers nos compatriotes de ces
départements ultramarins que nous ne
sommes pas en train de porter une loi
qui une fois de plus va porter atteinte
à l'égalité sociale entre les résidents
des départements d'outre-mer et ceux de
métropole c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous estimons que ce rapport nous savons
qu'elle est l'attitude générale du Sénat
sur cette question mais ce rapport est
particulièrement important je vous
remercie
s'il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de votre je vais donc
mettre vous à cet amendement 608 avec
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement quelles sont ceux qui sont
pour
contre
abstention n'est pas adoptée
nous passons une série d'amendements en
discussion communes nous commençons par
deux amendements identiques le premier
et le 223 présenté par Monsieur
chanterelle qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président retour dans
la salle des conférences du Palais du
Luxembourg siège du Sénat pendant
l'examen de cette réforme des retraites
avec un nouveau rebondissement ce matin
pour en parler j'accueil sur ce plateau
Rémi Cardon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de la somme alors
pour expliquer ce qui s'est passé le
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno Retailleau devait présenter ce
matin un amendement en amendement
important dans le débat puisqu'il
accélère la suppression de certains
régimes spéciaux de retraite qui est
prévu par cette réforme des retraites et
finalement la droite territoriale a
décidé de reporter le débat sur cet
amendement à plus tard dans l'examen de
cette réforme qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Rémi Cardon la droite c'est
notoriale refuse de débattre elle refuse
de démo puis surtout la tendance à
changer les règles du jeu à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'on remarque et puis en plus
de ça moi j'appelle ça en fait de
l'obstruction en réalité parce que vous
décalez ça vous voulez faire ça tout
simplement la réalité c'est ils veulent
faire le débat dans la nuit c'est qu'ils
ont peur d'assumer devant les Français
ce qui va faire c'est d'accélérer la des
régimes spéciaux dans le temps parce que
c'est un amendement de ce type en
réalité ce qu'on remarque c'est que
Monsieur Retailleau cherche toujours à
changer les règles du jeu donc ça
s'appelle de l'obstruction et en plus de
ça il va il va aller plus loin que le
gouvernement dans ce dans la dans cette
réforme des retraites alors on voit la
complicité entre le gouvernement qui
active le 47-1 et Monsieur Retailleau
qui active soit l'article 38 soit le 44
pour maintenant changer les l'ordre des
des articles du passage de l'article bon
voilà on voit clairement moi j'invite à
me suivre Retailleau de revenir dans le
débat de fond de se calmer parce que
l'argument c'est on nous coupe
l'électricité dans des permanences et du
coup on décale le débat enfin qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire enfin moi je ne
comprends pas
climat social qui est tendu dans cette
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites avec effectivement des actions
qui sont menées par certains opposants
des coupures d'électricité qui peuvent
toucher des personnes malades qui ont
besoin de respirateur également des
établissements
stratégie de rallonger les débats voire
d'obstruction alors ce que je remarque
c'est que la droite c'est latérale
change de change de méthode à chaque
fois un coup c'est on a on a pas eu le
temps de regarder les sous-amendement un
autre coup bon on est sous un moment on
les a pas forcément regarder mais ils
sont ils recevables un autre coup c'est
bon figurez-vous on va vous activer pour
aller très vite sur ses amendements on
voit la fin en fait on sent on sent la
panique en fait c'est toi la panique
merci beaucoup Rémi Cardon d'être venu
sur le plateau de Public Sénat on va
tout de suite rejoindre l'hémicycle du
Sénat ou les sénateurs continuent à
examiner les articles additionnels après
le fameux article 7 de cette réforme des
retraites il faut quand même le signaler
en repoussant le débat et ça montre que
vous voulez pas le débat
ce que ce que je veux vous dire aussi à
travers ces amendements les Français
établis hors de France vous allez
prendre et vous avez souvent pris des
situations à l'international en disant
regardez la base c'est 65 ans c'est 67
ans et vous ne connaissiez pas vraiment
le sujet nous on le connaît parce que la
plupart de nos compatriotes vivent dans
ces pays donc on peut très bien vous
rapporter des témoignages des
conséquences justement de ces réformes
dans ces pays et je peux vous dire que
la plupart du temps les pays que vous
prenez d'ailleurs vous prenez pas tout
parce qu'il y a des pays aussi des
endroits où c'est à 60 ans par exemple
c'est le cas dans celui dans lequel j'ai
vécu dans la province du Québec où c'est
à 60 ans après il y a un système
différent bien évidemment mais c'est
quand même à partir de 60 ans donc il
faut regarder les choses dans
l'entièreté et les pays justement qui
poussent plus tard c'est de la pauvreté
souvent je peux vous dire que c'est des
taux de pauvreté pratiquement les plus
importants c'est ça que vous voulez
vendre à notre société c'est-à-dire
d'avoir des personnes âgées pauvres
c'est pas ça en tout cas que nous nous
souhaitons défendre et le l'intérêt
d'avoir de ce recul que nous avons ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que nous
ne faisons pas de l'obstruction
l'obstruction et de ce banc là c'est
pour ça que nous avons mis ces
amendements pour que nos compatriotes
établir de France puissent également
apparaître dans ce débat parce que c'est
important également qu'ils apparaissent
dans ce débat mais bien évidemment nous
retirons les autres sous un moment
monsieur le Président c'est entendu et
dans la discussion commune nous avons
encore le 2017 présenté par Madame
Conway Mouret qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
en effet la réforme que vous proposez un
pacte négativement sur la vie de 68
millions de Français dont les trois
millions que vous avez oublié comme
vient de le rappeler mon collègue Yann
chanterelle dans ce texte ceux qui ont
choisi de vivre à l'étranger alors ils
l'ont bien compris et notamment la
moitié de la population qui représente
les femmes et qui vous font savoir en
manifestant massivement qu'il n'en
veulent pas manifestation d'ailleurs qui
ont eu lieu également à l'étranger
notamment à Berlin et à Madrid pourtant
vous ont été alors que l'examen du texte
a mis en lumière les grands oubliés de
votre réforme celles et ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées c'est malheureusement
le cas de tous nos compatriotes qui font
le choix de la mobilité et qui vivent à
l'étranger pendant une période plus ou
moins longue certains ont travaillé en
France c'est parfois dans plusieurs
autres pays et selon l'Observatoire de
l'Espace création 39% des séjours à
l'étranger sont motivés par une
opportunité professionnelle et pas moins
de 25% pour des raisons sentimentales
alors elles sont nombreuses car ce sont
majoritairement des femmes même si nous
avons un nombre croissant d'hommes à
renoncer à exercer une activité
professionnelle afin de suivre leur
conjoint au poste à l'étranger et mettre
fin parfois une carrière prometteuse il
est pas toujours facile de retrouver du
travail en France au retour ni à
l'étranger pendant l'expatriation c'est
donc bien la grande majorité de celles
et ceux qui sont souvent nos meilleurs
ambassadeurs et ambassadrices à
l'étranger qui sont directement
concernés par votre réforme c'est
pourquoi nous demandons au gouvernement
de remettre au Parlement un rapport
examinant les conséquences économiques
et sociales du relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite à 64 ans pour les Français
établis hors de France
et enfin le dernier amendement dans
cette discussion commune n'est pas
défendue donc nous avons trois
amendements sur lesquels il nous avons
besoin de la ville de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur 223 2017 et
effectivement chers
c'est tout à fait important de prendre
de
s'intéresser
aux assurés établis hors de France ainsi
que leurs conjoints et de voir un peu
comment sont pris ces interruptions
professionnelles se posent également le
cas de des femmes françaises qui
accouchent dans un pays étranger en
suivant leur conjoint et puis qui quand
elle rentre n'ont pas également
les trimestres par exemple de majoration
prise en compte où elles ont un blanc
dans leur carrière donc c'est un sujet
très intéressant mais qui a déjà été
largement largement étudi é notamment
par le corps et vous monsieur
chanterelles qui semblait si j'ai bien
compris tout savoir puisque les autres
ne savaient rien c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit
mille excuses mais monsieur chanterelle
on discutera juste en aparté par exemple
sur les différences entre le régime
Suisse et le régime en Ouzbékistan qui
nous permettra je pense d'être très
constructif dans le débat donc il y aura
un rapport défavorable mais peut-être
que Monsieur le Ministre d'une année des
précisions par rapport à ce sujet
d'importance monsieur le ministre sur
ces trois amendements la vie du
gouvernement
mais merci monsieur le Président comme
vous le savez comme Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénators le savent de
manière très générale il y a toujours
des exceptions mais de manière générale
le gouvernement s'oppose aux demandes de
rapport considérant que pour bien des
sujets les les compétences du Parlement
en matière de mission d'information de
commission d'enquête d'évaluation du
contrôle du gouvernement sont là pour
permettre la remise et la production de
rapport soit un rythme et avec une forme
d'objectivité plus importante que
lorsqu'il s'agit de le confier au
gouvernement sur l'autorité des
différents ministres qui dirigent les
services donc la vie est défavorable
ceci étant dit j'ai eu l'occasion de
répondre à Monsieur fracas ainsi qu'à
madame garomeda il y a quelques jours
sur la question des Français d'étrangers
pour dire que un rapport ne suffirait
pas à régler les difficultés rencontrées
par nos ressortissants à l'étranger
qu'il y a des difficultés
conventionnelles que chaque situation
renvoie à une nécessité d'une convention
d'un accord fiscal et social parfois les
deux avec les pays concernés tant pour
les questions de transfert de droit les
questions de 20 secondes pension des
questions de fiscalisation ou non de ces
pensions ainsi que sur la difficulté que
monsieur fraça avait pointé vous avez
pointé monsieur chanterelle concernant
le choix du pays et l'impossibilité de
faire une valeur des droits dans des
pays différents je me suis engagé au
tout début de ces débats parce qu'un
groupe de travail transpartisan avec les
parlementaires sénateurs et députés des
Français étrangers puissent avancer sur
ces sujets là et j'ai précisé que ça
sera un travail de fourmi et titanesque
dans le même temps puisqu'il faudra en
réalité examiner la situation de chaque
pays faire en sorte de pouvoir avancer
ou d'espérer dans une relation
bilatérale qui nécessite un accord
partagé je le rappelle de sur chacun des
sujets et ensuite avoir des projets de
loi des propositions permettant les
ratifications des conventions donc ça
n'est que le début d'un long processus
mais processus auquel je me suis engagé
le suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste et que
lui c'est républicains sur l'amendement
223 qui a fait l'objet de deux avis des
favorables
il n'y a pas de demande d'explication de
vote avant ce vote
je me suis président
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
bien entendu les explications de
Monsieur le de Monsieur ministre mais
c'est vrai que on voit que c'est un
sujet c'est un sujet important et que
justement pour le coup l'exception sur
un sur une demande de rapport environ à
2,5 millions de Françaises et de
Français vivent à l'étranger ça a été
rappelé et pour autant pas un mot de
leur situation dans la réforme des
retraites du gouvernement c'est
évidemment un oubli de taille car il
sont trop souvent pénalisés par
disposition existantes et subirer le
plein fouet les conséquences de
certaines mesures prévues par ce projet
de loi ils sont pénalisés parce que les
Françaises des Français étrangers ont
souvent des carrières morcelées
notamment parce que hier ont tendance à
changer de poste plus fréquemment les
quatre personnes ayez à travailler dans
plusieurs et dans différents pays ne
sont pas rares de tel parcours
professionnels morcelé sont de plus en
plus fréquents d'un côté de plus en plus
de Françaises et de français par
travailler à l'étranger de l'autre côté
les entreprises ont de moins en moins
recours aux détachement mais font signer
davantage de contrat de travail locaux
donc on voit bien en fait par rapport à
l'ensemble de ces arguments et par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre j'entends le le la
proposition en tout cas qui a un groupe
de travail et que et qu'on a on sera
attentif en tout cas à la création de ce
groupe à de ce groupe de travail mais
c'est vrai que je pense que là il me
semblait tôt nécessaire en tout cas
qu'on inscrive le fait qu'un rapport
soit demandé et qui puisse nous éclairer
sur cette situation
avant le mode sur le 223
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'entends votre votre argument
et je sais que les rapports sont pas ne
sont pas populaires et généralement
rejeté cependant la demande d'un rapport
permet d'abord d'avoir un calendrier
puisque le rapport doit être remis et
même si on est fait un groupe de travail
et bien évidemment s'il est
parlementaires sont conviés à le
rejoindre et bien nous serons de cela
[Musique]
comment
permettrait quand même de pouvoir
avancer sur ce sujet je ne pense pas
qu'il faille revoir l'ensemble des
conventions fiscales elle peut bien sûr
bien sûr être étudiée mais le rapport
permet de rassembler l'ensemble de ces
argumentaires et surtout d'avancer dans
un calendrier qui sera donné parce que
comme vous l'avez mentionné c'est un
travail de fourmi mais cela veut dire
que il va prendre des années et que
finalement nous ne serons pas assez
rapidement l'impact que cette réforme
aura sur les Français vivant à
l'étranger ou plus particulièrement pour
ceux qui veulent partir à l'étranger et
qui ont besoin d'avoir une information
complète quant à ce qui les attend quand
ils rentreront en France un jour
puis à Monsieur Leconte puis à Monsieur
chanterelle
oui monsieur le Président moi je
soutiendrai vraiment très fermement
cette demande de rapport d'autant que
j'ai posé une question écrite au mandat
précédent sur effectivement la
problématique des retraites pour nos
compatriotes qui sont à l'étranger je
n'ai pas eu de réponse
ma question est devenue obsolète
je l'ai reposée je tiens à dire que je
l'ai reposé et donc si ce rapport était
voté je retirerais ma question écrite ce
qui permettra au gouvernement d'avoir de
meilleurs taux statistiques de réponse
aux questions écrites des parlementaires
3 oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre des chers collègues
compte tenu des des spécificités
finalement des personnes qui font une
partie de leur carrière à
l'international ça n'est pas simplement
le sujet des Français à l'étranger c'est
d'une manière générale les personnes qui
font une partie de leur carrière
internationale la manière dont ils
n'auront pas de décote parce qu'ils ont
fait des années à l'étranger la manière
dont on va compter leurs années en
France alors que la moitié ici la moitié
de leur carrière est fait à
l'international et ben les 25 meilleures
années c'est toutes leurs années de
carrière pour je pense aussi en
particulier au fonctionnaires qui sont
détachés et qui travaillent en
particulier dans nos écoles françaises à
l'étranger en recrutement local je pense
aussi aux personnes qui travaillent en
recrutement local dans nos services
diplomatiques et consulaires et qui
n'ont pas accès parfois à la retraite
française surtout ces sujets monsieur le
ministre les dispositions pourraient
être législatives mais elles sont
d'abord réglementaires ça relève aussi
de la manière dont on interprète
l'application des conventions fiscales
et donc un rapport pose la position du
gouvernement à son intérêt donc bien
entendu il convient de voter ses
amendements mais quoi qu'il arrive des
travaux pour faire pour permettre de
faire évoluer la réglementation sur les
sujets qui nous tiennent à cœur en
particulier l'absence de décote l'accès
à la capacité de cotiser à la retraite
lorsqu'on travaille pour les services
français à l'étranger en recrutement
local ce sont des sujets qui méritent
effectivement que nous échangeons tous
ensemble le plus rapidement dans un
groupe de travail parce que si vous
posez maintenant à la condition de d'âge
pour liquider la retraite à 64 ans pour
un certain nombre de Français qui
vivaient à l'étranger dans des pays où
la retraite est à 60 ans ça pose aussi
une difficulté et il y aura pendant
quelques années un certain nombre de
personnes qui auront besoin d'aller au
consulat demander les allocations de
solidarité ce qui est aussi une
difficulté monsieur chanterelle et
ensuite madame Vogel oui monsieur le le
Président nous avons bien pris note
monsieur le ministre votre ouverture et
la création de un groupe transpartisans
évidemment nous y participerons pour
pouvoir améliorer la situation de nos
compatriotes établies hors de France et
permettre ses avancées mais je voudrais
répondre aussi à Monsieur Savary puisque
je ne peux pas rester sans réponse vous
dites vous savez tout mais vous savez je
suis quand même un des représentants
donc compatriotes établi hors de France
à travers vos propos vous les insultez
aussi moi je vous donne pas de leçon sur
la situation dans la Marne donc je vous
demanderai un peu de respect parce que
c'est ce que nous faisons nous pouvons
d'ailleurs et c'est tout à l'honneur
notre émission débattre des fois c'est
durement sur le fond mais je pense qu'il
y a un respect minimal qui devrait être
de séances entre nous et de ne pas se
livrer à ce genre à ce genre d'attaque
puisque vous passez beaucoup de temps à
parler du fait de vouloir débattre sur
le fond donc faites-le appliquez-le à
vous-même et continuons nos débats
intervenez d'ailleurs c'est toujours
très intéressant quand vous intervenez
sur le fond pour que nous puissions
consulter sereinement nos débats sur le
fond et d'étudier tous les amendements
que nous avons déposés merci à vous
madame Vogel explique son vote
madame Vogel c'est à vous pour expliquer
votre vote oui merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président donc la raison pour
laquelle nous avons déposé ces
amendements ça a été très bien expliqué
par mes collègues c'est que
nous sommes dans une situation où les
Françaises et les Français qui sont
établis hors de France ont souvent eu
une partie de leur carrière en France
une partie de leur carrière à l'étranger
parfois dans différents pays parfois ils
reviennent en France parfois pas et ils
sont un peu et elles sont un peu dans la
situation au fond des femmes en France
qui ont des carrières hachées sauf que
dans beaucoup de circonstances ces
Françaises et des Français n'ont même
pas eu des carrières hachées c'est
simplement que la manière dont on
calcule leur salaire annuel moyen la
manière dont on liquide la retraite et
discriminatoire puisque on obtient pas
compte des années effectuées à
l'étranger donc on est dans une
situation où le fait d'avoir
étudié ailleurs travailler ailleurs qui
participent de la richesse du monde de
la richesse de nos sociétés ces Français
les Français qui apporte tellement à
l'étranger mais qui est aussi rapport
tellement en France au fond son
pénalisés pour avoir une carrière pas
uniquement en France et donc la seule
chose qu'on vous qu'on vous demande
c'est simplement de faire un rapport
pour étudier la manière dont cette
réforme en particulier qui comme elle va
affecter en particulier toutes les
personnes en France qui ont des
carrières arrachées puisque ça deviendra
plus difficile d'atteindre les 64 ans va
aussi en particulier affecter beaucoup
les Françaises et les Français de
l'étranger il est elles sont dans des
situations très variables il y a
beaucoup de situations des pays où il y
a des conventions des pays où il y en a
pas autant de situations que de français
et de français néanmoins je crois qu'on
a vraiment besoin d'avoir une
objectivation de des conséquences sur
leurs droits c'est la raison pour
laquelle on vous demande un rapport il y
a 3 millions de personnes qui va à
l'étranger je pense que c'est pas
beaucoup demandé que simplement de
savoir quel vers l'impact sur leur vie
sur leur droite de cette réforme je vous
remercie donc nous avons deux
amendements en discute identiques sur
lesquels nous allons prononcer nous
avons d'ailleurs deux demandes de
scrutin public sur ces deux amendements
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions de l'article 56
le scrutin est ouvert
oral du gouvernement et de la Commission
le Sénat continue son examen de la
réforme des retraites que vous suivez en
direct sur Public Sénat et sénateur vote
actuellement sur un amendement qui
demande un rapport sur les conséquences
de cette réforme de retraite pour les
français établi hors de France
l'expatriation qui entraîne parfois des
carrières hachées avec des conjoints qui
sont obligés de suivre leur conjoint à
l'étranger et cela a forcément des
impacts sur leur carrière et donc au
final sur leurs pensions de retraite ce
sont des amendements venus de la gauche
qui demandent la publication et de ce
rapport sur les conséquences de cette
réforme des retraites les sénateurs
votent actuellement par scrutin public
sur leur tablette électronique des
scrutins publiques qui sont demandés
assez souvent par la gauche notamment
pour rallonger les débats
voici le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat votre temps 344
exprimé 343 pour les amendements 93
contre 250 ils ne sont donc pas adoptés
et sur le troisième amendement
discussion commune 2017 de Madame Conway
Moret nous avons également une demande
de scrutin
qui va être annoncé
et il va être procédé dans les
conditions de l'article 56 avec double
avis défavorable le scrutin est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à voter sur
un nouvel amendement qui demande un
rapport pour établir les conséquences de
cette réforme de retraite sur les
Français établir de France a noté que
dans la nuit hier la majorité de droite
et du centre du Sénat à voter le fameux
article 7 de cette réforme des retraites
qui reporte l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans après deux journées de soirée et de
nuit de débat intense autour de cet
article 7
les résultats sont les suivants votants
344 exprimés 343 pour 93 contre 250 il
n'est pas adopté nous en venons à
l'amendement 2392 qui est présenté par
Monsieur Joly et ses collègues sur le
président féministe mes chers collègues
vous le savez comme moi la l'évolution
démographique de la France va conduire à
la croissance dans les prochaines années
continuent de la part des personnes
âgées
ce vieillissement était hogène sur le
territoire national enfin en définitive
on constate départ de population
âgées plus importantes dans les zones
urbaines que dans les zones dans les
zones rurales plus que dans les zones
urbaines avec des écarts vraiment très
sensibles puisque une part de la
population en
Île-de-France des personnes de plus de
60 ans qui est de 11 de 15,5% et avec
des maximales qui sont dans Limousin
pour le prendre exemple d'une région
après 30% et au-delà de 30% parce qu'il
concerne le département de la Creuse
outre les écarts entre les régions les
retraités semblent donc en proportion je
le disais plus nombreuses sur les
territoires ruraux cet amendement
demande donc au gouvernement de remettre
un rapport au Parlement examinant les
conséquences économiques et sociales du
relèvement de l'âge de la retraite à 64
ans pour les Français vivant dans les
zones rurales au regard de ce que de
ceux qui vivent dans les zones urbaines
l'enjeu est une compréhension des
spécificités du vieillissement milieu
rural et de leurs principes
organisateurs c'est un enjeu qui tient
essentiel pour un rapport essentiel bon
appréhender l'aménagement des
territoires le développement des
services médico-sociaux en direction des
populations RG l'accompagnement social
des parcours de vie dans la vieillesse
et permettre le développement d'une
action publique adéquate et pertinente
en effet les territoires ruraux sont ne
sont pas tous également préparés face
aux vieillissement voire à la géronto
croissance et qu'il est concerne et les
politiques locales prennent diverses
solutions qui le convient d'examiner
d'analyser de diagnostic quai pour
pouvoir les adapter voilà le sens de cet
amendement c'est une des conséquences
particulières de cette loi est article 7
qui a été évoquée sur les territoires
ruraux de la même manière qu'on a évoqué
cela à l'occasion d'autres débats les
conséquences liées aux catégories aux
typologies aux natures d'emploi
différentes dans les territoires ruraux
par rapport au territoire urbain je vous
remercie quelle est la vie de la
Commission
merci c'est une demande de rapport donc
avis défavorable sachant que ce sujet
ont déjà étudié dans nombre étaient
étudié dans nombre d'articles de presse
ou à travers les organismes qui
planchent sur les problèmes de retraite
je me vois cet amendement 23,92 avec
double avis défavorable qui est
favorable
qui est contre cet amendement
abstention il est pas adopté toujours
après l'article 7 nous avons
l'amendement 3161
présenté par Madame pensé manger ses
collègues elle a la parole
merci monsieur le Président à
l'argenticipe qu'on puisse me reprocher
que ce n'est pas dans cette loi qu'il
fallait mettre mon amendement mais dans
la loi immigration parce qu'en fin de
compte si vous voulez toutes ces études
ont un point commun c'est qu'elle montre
l'insuffisance de l'étude d'impact faut
dire qu'il a pas été il a pas été fait
par le Conseil d'État et donc tous ces
rapports effectivement
demande des rapports sur des points
particuliers de l'impact de cette loi
c'est aussi simple que ça et c'est ça le
lien alors selon une étude de l'Insee
les émigrés représentent moins de 10% de
la population française il représente
par contre 20 % des personnes pauvres
et je vous rappelle que 62 ans 25% des
personnes les plus pauvres et bien sûr
pas toutes les pauvres sont déjà
décédées parmi ces derniers les les
personnes immigrées sont très sur
représentées une part des travailleurs
immigrés ont des caractères des
carrières hachées donc on rejoint
l'amendement précédent notamment en
raison de discrimination à l'embauche on
sait que c'est un des facteurs de
discrimination les plus forts ils sont
souvent après au chômage
8,5% en moyenne contre 4,7% pour les non
immigrés et et ils sont aussi ent
souvent tardivement sur le marché du
travail français de plus et je tiens le
souligner dans leur relevé de carrière
il manque effectivement souvent de
nombreuses années non déclarées par les
employeurs et ils payent de façon
massive le prix fort de pratique
illégale d'employeurs exploitateurs
donc du fait de carrière à faible
salaire un complexe beaucoup de
travailleurs immigrés vivent avec la SPA
scission droit sera représenté dans les
métiers et les secteurs j'en ai parlé
hier les ouvriers les employés qui vont
payer le prix le plus fort de cette
réforme les travailleurs étrangers donc
pâtiront d'autant de façon
proportionnellement plus forte du recul
de l'âge de la reprenne voilà l'objet de
cette amende l'avis de la commission sur
l'amendement 3161 madame le rapporteur
général oui chers collègues la vie est
toujours défavorable et c'est vrai que
on aurait pu demander je sais pas moi
1000 rapports sur catégorie sur telle
statut sur telle conséquence de cette
réforme sur sur
les retraités mais en réalité vous avez
aussi une étude d'impact vous l'avez
certainement vu chers collègues parce
que je sais combien vous êtes attentive
à repérer tous les éléments de réflexion
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup et de la
part de la CNAV et de la part du
ministère un certain nombre d'éléments
qui ont été donnés et je pense que on
est tous renseignés après qu'il y ait
effectivement des catégories ou des
personnes qui sont en situation
difficile je ne le nie pas et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces personnes en
particulier que nous nous sommes engagés
pour la plupart d'entre nous c'est pour
défendre ces réalités difficiles
cependant demander des rapports c'est
sans doute très contradictoire avec
votre volonté d'avoir des réponses à vos
questions écrites aussi parce qu'on peut
pas demander au ministère de lancer des
lancer des rapports des rapports et des
rapports et demander aussi des questions
écrites des questions écrites et des
questions écrites je crois qu'il faut
être raisonnable en tout et si on doit
retrouver la sérénité il faut retrouver
le raisonnable dans nos demandes c'est
un avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre votre avis
j'ai pas bien entendu c'est défavorable
monsieur le ministre c'était bien
défavorable
j'ai une demande de scrutin public
demandée par le groupe écologiste sur
cet amendement 3161
le scrutin
va être annoncé
conformément à l'article 56 le scrutin
est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à débattre
de cette réforme des retraites avec
actuellement un scrutin public sur des
amendements qui portent sur les articles
additionnels après l'article 7 on le
rappelle la nuit dernière le Sénat a
voté en faveur de cet article 7 qui
reporte l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
les sénateurs sont en train d'examiner
les derniers amendements après cet
article 7 et après bien le Sénat devrait
passer à l'article 8 et on en parlera
dans quelques instants
344 exprimé 343 pour le moment 93 contre
250 il n'est pas adopté et il nous reste
3186 également présenté par Madame
pocemonge qui a la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
selon une étude du Centre du Centre
d'étude de l'emploi et du travail la
réforme de 2010 c'est intéressant à
sensiblement augmenter le nombre d'arrêt
maladie de longue durée chez les seniors
pour un surco estimer à 68 millions
d'euros cette étude laisse à penser
qu'un nouveau repas et il sera plus
grave je suppose
qu'à nouveau rapport de l'âge la
vulnérabilité augmentant avec l'âge
et la moindre résistance des seniors à
l'intensité du travail
auprès oppressions temporelles va y
compris aux accidents professionnels va
aller croissant et que ça risque ça
risque ça va se traduire par des
surcoûts pour l'assurance maladie et la
TNT sans que cela ne soit vraiment
analysé et d'ailleurs il comprit dans
les tableaux d'équilibre par ailleurs de
nombreuses études concluent un effet
négatif de l'allongement de la vie
active sur la santé qu'elle soit
objectivement décrite c'est à dire par
des études scientifiques ou
auto-évaluées et l'augmentation de la
prévalence des taux de dépression et des
troubles mentaux par le travail n'est
pas un phénomène anodin puisqu'il serait
à l'origine de 20% des arêtes de travail
à cet âge un chiffre en constante
augmentation depuis 2016 nous notons
donc que vous ne prenez pas suffisamment
contre les effets de la réforme
sur le système de santé
et l'augmentation des arrêts maladie
l'augmentation prolongée par exemple de
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
provoquant des maladies
ultérieurement à la période de travail
et enfin les répercussions de ce report
de là sur la santé perçue et objective
comme le montre un certain nombre
d'études et tout cela du fait des
inégalités de santé oui j'ai parlé de
deux enfermes parce qu'à ces âges
l'impact sur la santé ces deux ans ferme
il l'a commission sur un rendement 3186
madame le rapporteur je pense que
madame
il
IAS maladie et la branche vieillesse et
il y a du lien entre la branche
vieillesse et puis la branche autonomie
tout ça c'est on est d'accord et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui constitue la sécurité
sociale c'est pour cette raison que moi
j'ai pas été choqué que ce soit porté
cette réforme des retraites par CE plfsr
et donc
vous demandez un rapport une nouvelle
fois mais je crois que nous avons chaque
année l'opportunité de regarder
précisément le rapport qu'il y a entre
ces différentes branches et
je vous laisse à penser que c'est ce
qu'on fera à la prochaine saison de
discussion sur la sécurité sociale
c'est vrai que plus on avance en âge et
puis on peut avoir des difficultés je
pense que chacun peut rendre compte on
vieillit on prend de l'âge et il y a des
difficultés qui arrivent mais pour
autant est-ce que on doit parler de de
cette difficulté là maintenant alors que
il y a encore en attente beaucoup de
sujets beaucoup de sujets qui sont
importants notamment
les bornes d'âge la pénibilité justement
qui fera du lien aussi avec votre sujet
moi je pense que là vous essayez de
gagner du temps et c'est très pénible
c'est un avis défavorable
mais ma vie que la Commission madame
ponce pour expliquer votre vote
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
oublié de répondre à Madame la
rapporteur sur mes questions écrites non
là vraiment il n'y a pas d'inflation
c'est pas comme l'inflation des prix
j'ai posé depuis 2020 où je suis
sénatrice 15 questions écrites 8 ont eu
une réponse j'attends les 7 routes je
pense que c'est tout à fait sobre et je
suis assez pour la sobriété de ce point
de vue
favorable à cet amendement numéro 3186
après double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté nous
emmenons à l'article 8 sur lequel madame
ponce est inscrite puis plusieurs autres
orateurs c'est à vous sur l'article 8
et pour ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
Public Sénat le Sénat va commencer
l'examen de l'article 8 de la réforme
des retraites qui concernent les
carrières longues après l'adoption hier
soir de l'article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans alors début des débats aujourd'hui
sur l'article 8 qui concerne précisément
les départs anticipés et notamment les
carrières longues car et bien vous le
savez malgré le report de l'âge à 64 ans
le gouvernement a quand même conservé un
dispositif de départ anticipé pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt avec
plusieurs seuils ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans pour en partir à
58 ans s'ils ont tout leur trimestre
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
16 et 18 ans pourront commencer pourront
partir à 60 ans et puis pour ceux entre
18 et 20 ans ils pourront partir à 62
ans ces carrières longues ça a été
l'objet d'un débat ou le à l'Assemblée
nationale et de tractations entre les
républicains et le gouvernement avec
notamment le député
qui a mis la pression sur le
gouvernement pour faire des concessions
sur ce dispositif carrière longue
Elizabeth borne a d'ailleurs annoncé des
concessions durant le débat l'Assemblée
nationale les travailleurs qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21 ans
pourront partir à 63 ans et ce qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 17 ans
pourront partir à 60 ans voilà
maintenant le débat sur les carrières
longues qui n'a pas eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale va voir lieu au
Sénat et je vous le propose de le suivre
en direct avec des amendements de
suppression qui sont défendus par la
gauche n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et va même renforcer la précarisation
des sites des personnes en situation de
handicap je sais que vous n'avez pas
bougé l'âge mais justement la quête
trouve que vous auriez dû le bouger dans
un sens de le réduire il aura pareil en
effet contestable de présenter certaines
mesures de statu quo ou de faible
avancée tels que le maintien de la
retraite anticipée pour inaptitude à 62
ans ou pour handicap à 55 ans comme du
progrès c'est ce que je vous disais hier
quand vous n'aggravez pas vous pour vous
c'est un progrès et bien la caisse
effectivement dit que vous n'êtes pas au
rendez-vous selon le collectif handicap
le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans va
pénaliser les personnes en situation de
handicap qui elles ne peuvent pas
bénéficier des dispositifs dérogatoires
à 60 à 55 ans pardon mais qui rencontre
de grandes difficultés pour se maintenir
en emploi
et donc elle passe en moyenne elle 8 et
demi sans emploi
dans mon intervention merci ensuite
madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le président
vous nous présentez cette réforme comme
un projet porteur de justice sociale et
de progrès nous ne sommes pas dupe de
votre hypocrisie vous faites passer pour
une avancée sociale le simple maintien
de la retraite anticipée à 70 ans pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
nous devrions donc nous satisfaire de
cela
quand on sait qu'à l'origine ces
personnes connaissent des difficultés
dans le monde du travail en raison de
leur limitation qu'elle rencontre aussi
des soucis dans le scolarité que
l'environnement
urbain est inadapté à leur mode de vie
on ne peut que déplorer une fois de plus
que le gouvernement n'intègre pas
davantage les situations les citoyens en
situation de handicap dans sa politique
de réforme sociale
pourtant
19% des Français en situation de
handicap vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté contre 13% de la population
générale d'après un rapport de ligase en
date du 16 décembre 2022 les retraités
déclarés inapt vivent en moyen 4 à 6 ans
de moins que les autres traités si je
résume les personnes en situation de
handicap trouve difficilement du travail
sont plus précaires que le reste de la
population qui les exclut vive moins
longtemps et dans de moins bonnes
conditions quoi qu'il arrive des
travailleurs handicapés sont perdants et
vous échouez à leur garantir une vie
digne et une retraite digne votre texte
souligne particulièrement sur ce point
un manque d'ambition client comme tous
les restes de votre politique la
solidarité l'inclusion l'intégration
sont des mots slogans que vous ne
comptez jamais mettre en pratique merci
ensuite
les orateurs de groupe puisque c'est
notre règle monsieur joignandais pour
les présidents cet article 8 est très
important pour notre groupe des
Républicains puisque c'est à cette
occasion que nous voulons vraiment faire
une avancée importante pour les femmes
et notamment pour les pour les maires de
famille
je voudrais interroger
occasion de cet article 8 le ministre
monsieur le ministre s'il vous plaît
j'aurais vraiment besoin avec les
quelques vins sénateurs qui ont signé
mon amendement sur la question des 43
ans d'explication précise les carrières
longues à certains nombres d'entre nous
n'y comprennent rien
nous avons déposé un amendement pour
simplifier les choses ok pour les 64 ans
j'ai voté nous avons voté les 64 ans il
y a la question des 43 ans pour
équilibrer les choses nous souhaiterions
que c'est 43 ans soit une limite maximum
de cotisations on a 43 ans on s'en va
alors si on dit ça et si on amende
au gouvernement c'est l'avant centre qui
se couche dans les 18 mètres pour avoir
un penalty ça s'appelle de la simulation
et bien quand l'arbitre quand l'arbitre
quand l'arbitre ne s'en aperçoit pas
quand l'arbitre ne s'en aperçoit pas et
bien siffle la penalty mais quand ils en
aperçoit ils doivent et je souhaite
que nos concitoyens ouvrent les yeux je
ne peux pas amender en raison de votre
obstruction merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre nous avons encore
deux collègues inscrits pour parler sur
l'article et donc je propose que si vous
voulez ajouter des observations vous le
fassiez après
vous préférez le faire avant la fin des
orateurs et bien les yeux monsieur le
président
j'entends dans mon oreille derrière moi
il y a pas de pénalty quand on est
hors-jeu je trouve que c'est une belle
expression
mes chers collègues
continuons à travailler avec un peu de
sang-froid
je je vous le dis très tranquillement
vous ne pouvez pas
reprocher à votre position de faire
simplement son travail de position alors
que en étant majoritaire vous disposez
d'outils de ce règlement intérieur qui
ont été d'ailleurs débloquer hier en
conférence des présidents et je pense à
l'article 42 10 en particulier qui vient
se rajouter à l'article 38 que vous
utilisez manière sporadique plus le 42
16 etc le déplacement d'amendement
revient sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Retailleau donc écoutez on peut à chaque
fois vous faire un rappel au règlement
pour nous dire pour vous dire respecter
votre position simplement comme nous
nous vous respectons et nous gagnerons
du temps pour pouvoir permettre le débat
merci monsieur le Président
nous poursuivons donc les prises de
parole une par groupe suivant l'accord
passé en conférence des présidents sur
l'article 8 il nous reste madame meunier
madame apource
pour le groupe centriste madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues nous vous le
disons depuis presque une semaine
maintenant cette réforme financière et
ce reportage légal à 64 ans comporte des
conséquences sociales graves les
rustines que vous nous proposez à
l'article 8
ne sont alors et ne tromperont pas les
millions de Françaises et de français
mobilisés contre cette réforme ainsi que
leur représentants là je veux relayer
les inquiétudes importantes du secteur
du handicap alors que cet article
prétend atténuer les injustices
et bien cet article risque au contraire
d'aggraver les inégalités d'accès au
départ anticipé pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et en situation
d'incapacité les travailleurs les plus
vulnérables sont pénalisés je parle là
des titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les personnes inapte au
travail les allocataires de la location
adulte handicapée les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs en
incapacité permanentes à la suite d'un
accident de travail ou d'une maladie
professionnelle je parle aussi des
fonctionnaires handicapés et vous dites
assouplir les conditions d'accès à la
retraite anticipée des travailleurs en
abaissant le taux d'incapacité
nécessaire à 50% et en remplaçant la
condition des trimestres validés par
celles des trimestres cotisés cette
durée de cotisation reste encore trop
longue pour les personnes en carrière
hachées et à la fatigabilité élevée la
substitution des trimestres validés par
les trimestres cotisés aura pour effet
de compliquer l'accès au dispositif nous
ne regrettons que ici la majorité
sénatoriale est déclarée ircevable de
nombreux amendements allant dans ce sens
pour corriger le tir la fixation de
l'âge de départ anticipé va aggraver
cette situation
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président après l'é
pisode
aux critique de traverser collectivement
nous nous plongeons dans la lecture de
l'article 8 le débat interne des
républicains sur l'adaptation des règles
de départ anticipées pour les carrières
longues conduisent-ils les droites à
accepter cette fois-ci à des bas
beaucoup plus large avec nous présenter
comme la caution sociale de cette
réforme cet article
prolonge en réalité
un statu quo injuste pour les
bénéficiaires du dispositif carrière
longue vos diversions ne trompent
personne à terme vous déclarez d'un an
l'âge de départ à la retraite pour
celles et ceux ayant commencé à
travailler à 18 ans après avoir mené la
guerre au régime pionnier vous vous
apprêtez à maintenir les seuls régimes
spéciaux injustes oui en imposant une
durée de cotisation majorée d'un an
porté à 44 annuités vous réservez un
traitement spécial à celle et ce ayant
commencé à 14 16 et 18 ans le vent tout
de suite le doute ce que vous présentez
comme des droits nouveaux constituants
en réalité des reculs des grands reculs
sociaux c'est recul concerne très peu de
personnes si en 2004 126
000 carrières longues partaient à la
retraite avant 60 ans ils étaient
seulement
238 en 2021 votre réforme n'y changera
rien vous décidez de reconduire ces
mesures uniquement parce qu'elles
s'inscrivent dans une dynamique
d'extinction du dispositif carrière
longue selon une projection de la CNAV
le nombre de bénéficiaires des retraites
anticipées pour carrière longue sera
divisée par deux dans 20 ans les
carrières hachées des femmes et des
jeunes y contribuent en pleinement la
droite au Sénat aura-t-elle le courage
de protéger les carrières longues en
supprimant les mesures d'âge pour les
travailleurs ayant commencé à cotiser
avant 21 ans
acteurs de groupe mais j'ai une demande
de scrute d'une demande de règlement de
rappels règlement mais le président
rénal accepte de le faire après donc
monsieur Canevet vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le groupe de l'Union centriste
est bien sûr satisfait que l'on puisse
enfin parler de vrais sujets
c'est-à-dire des sujets de cessation
progressive de l'activité ou anticipée
de l'activité d'usure professionnelle de
l'ensemble des mécanismes de solidarité
mais je vous rends attentif mes chers
collègues au fait que lors d'un failli
ne pas y arriver puisque le vrai débat
sur ce texte c'est quand même ça et
l'exemple de ce que l'on voit là c'est à
dire la succession de d'amendements du
même groupe pour exactement le même
objet supprimer le supprimer l'article
voilà n'a aucun sens ça veut dire que ça
prive notre capacité de débattre de réel
sujet de préoccupation de l'ensemble des
Français parce que le temps va
expliciter de façon redondante
ces amendements ce seront ce sera autant
de temps de moins que nous aurons nous
collègues du groupe de l'Union centrices
pour pouvoir exprimer véritablement
notre vision de la société notre vision
du sujet des retraites et cela en
l'observe depuis le début de la semaine
et depuis le week-end dernier et on
espère qu'en fin les oppositions seront
de compte qu'il faut que l'on débattre
du fond et non pas qu'on utilise des
artifices de procédure qui empêche qui
empêche réellement le débat du fond donc
j'espère que ils vont se ressaisir
qu'enfin on va pouvoir s'exprimer
le président rénal à la parole pour un
rappel au Règlement sur la base de
l'article 33 du règlement et sur la
prise de parole donc mettons en cause de
Monsieur joaillandé et puis d'ailleurs
je prendrai en même temps monsieur
camper dans la réponse si vous permettez
non je voudrais dire des choses assez
simples le premier point
relève de
l'argumentation monsieur je rendais en
disant on a dû retirer notre manque de
monde
mais la cause principale chers collègues
du retrait de votre amendement c'est le
fait qu'il y a aujourd'hui et je le dis
sans eux un accord entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement et non
mais c'est un accord qui fait que
certains abandonnants sont acceptés
préalablement et d'autres ne le sont pas
le vôtre ne l'a pas été par vos amis
aujourd'hui ne portez pas la
responsabilité sur nous je vous en prie
deuxième point et d'ailleurs il est
repris par Monsieur il est repris par
Monsieur kanvé vous dites on ouvre là
une séquence de je sais pas combien
d'amendements de suspension
identiques oui mais je vous rappelle
l'article 40 monsieur Canevet la
différence qu'il y a entre vous et nous
c'est que vous à juste titre je conteste
pas vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement et donc tout ce qui devait
passer et finalement est couvert par le
gouverte et couvert par le gouvernement
par l'intention le gouvernement et vous
permet de déposer des articles qui sinon
seraient article 40 et comme nous on n'a
pas cette possibilité et bien on est
obligé de le faire à travers un
abandonne suppression ce que vous savez
monsieur cadv par cœur vous le savez
parfaitement et donc là vous jouez un
jeu dangereux qui est de et oui et donc
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que la
l'idée monsieur Kennedy qui est derrière
votre peau d'ouvrir encore une fois le
38 c'est une fumisterie parce que on est
obligé de passer par ces amendements là
et qui vont lever nous qui vont nous
permettre de faire nos propres
propositions je vous remercie je crois
que le Sénat a parfaitement compris
votre
[Musique]
rappel au règlement est maintenant
monsieur joyeux en œuvre va en faire un
autre
et ensuite la commission s'exprimera
puis le gouvernement le président sur le
même article du règlement parce que j'ai
été mis en cause ce que vous dites est
faux mon cher collègue pourquoi cet
amendement était retiré ce matin parce
qu'à la lumière de l'expérience d'hier
soir vous avez mis 500 sous amendements
sur l'amendement de notre collection
triste qui a été obligé de retirer son
amendement donc il y a aucun problème
pour discuter il y a aucun problème pour
discuter de cet amendement ici au fond
et j'aurais bien été d'ailleurs
satisfait qu'on puisse en parler
ensemble de ce sujet des 43 ans
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai pas eu le temps
de dire tout à l'heure au ministre c'est
que j'attends des réponses très précises
sur ce sujet d'ailleurs j'ai voté les 64
ans pour moi la compensation ce sont les
43 ans de cotisations et j'attends les
réponses précises du ministre qui
conditionneront mon vote final sur
l'ensemble du texte de loi je le dis
parce que je pense que c'est une c'est
une question importante donc mon chers
collègues mon cher collègue il y a pas
tous les jeux que de que vous que vous
que vous imaginez je pense que vous êtes
dans un moment difficile
vous commencez à retirer vos sous
amendements parce que c'est de plus en
plus difficile pour vous de supporter et
d'expliquer votre stratégie parce que
vous vous jouez sur une chose vous vous
espérez vous espérez que nos concitoyens
ne vont pas comprendre vous les prenez
pour des oiseaux en essayant en essayant
en essayant en essayant de leur faire
croire que c'est nous qui faisons
d'obstruction en essayant de mais il
commence à s'en rendre compte il
commence à s'en rendre compte et c'est
pour ça que vous retirez vos sous
amendements parce que ça devient
insupportable ne prenez pas les français
pour des oiseaux et respecter
l'institution la grande institution du
Sénat j'ai été élu Benjamin cette maison
en 95 mes chers amis oui et ben je n'ai
jamais je n'ai jamais vu je n'ai jamais
vu
une opposition se comporter comme ça
c'est absolument détestable alors
madame Brulin souhaite également faire
un rappel au règlement et ensuite la
Commission va s'exprimer madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président mon rappel
au règlement se fonde sur le même
article et je voudrais féliciter de
notre collègue qui vient bien de parler
de ce que c'était une carrière longue
notamment sur ses bancs il faut il faut
mettre un peu d'humour et de détente
dans notre débat j'espère que vous
l'aurez considéré comme ça je voudrais
rassurer je voudrais rassurer nos
collègues chaque amélioration qui sera
apportée
sur quelle que soit le bande d'où elles
viennent nous les voterons et si
d'aventure nous devions sous amender des
amendements ce serait pour améliorer
encore les améliorations que vous-même
proposez vous aurez l'occasion de le
voir dans l'examen de cet article le
problème c'est effectivement que si vous
avez retiré votre amendement mon cher
collègue c'est le fruit d'un accord avec
le gouvernement parce que ce
gouvernement préfère négocier avec une
poignée de républicain qu'avec une
interfydicale unie et solide
je pense que ce n'est pour aucune autre
raison que vous avez retiré votre
amendement et vous ne ferez croire à
personne ici que vous l'avez retiré pour
empêcher nos sous amendements ou alors
vous vous déclarez à tout le monde que
vous renoncez améliorer la situation des
Français parce que vous ne le pouvez pas
ici je voudrais terminer en disant que
plus d'une cinquantaine de nos collègues
de droite et du centre ont refusé hier
de voter l'article 7 il s'en est ajouté
trois ce matin je voudrais féliciter ces
collègues qui ont fait cela qui ont fait
cela malgré sans doute de nombreuses
pressions dont ils ont été l'objet et
vous dire que les fissures et les
lézards qui commencent
vont s'amplifier
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur merci
merci
revenons un petit peu au fond du
problème un peu de sérénité dans les
débats je voulais vous exprimer ici
simplement
la philosophie de
adopté par votre commission des affaires
sociales en ce qui concerne l'ensemble
des dispositifs de ce texte voyez-vous
vous l'avez vu au niveau par exemple de
l'article 2 on a essayé de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse prendre en compte
davantage l'employabilité des seniors
par rapport à ce qui nous était proposé
et que cette réforme s'applique à tout
le monde c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons fait des propositions à la
fois par exemple pour les sonnets
orchidées au chômage des propositions
pour ceux qui étaient en emploi vous
voyez c'était construit autour de cette
volonté que l'on puisse faire répartir
cette effort collectif sur le plus de
personnes non pas pour les pénaliser
mais pour faire en sorte que
sur davantage il ne soit pas concentré
ces efforts sur certains dans le domaine
de la pénibilité vous le verrez à
l'article 9 nous pensons également qu'il
faut prendre des dispositions
différentes et vous verrez que à travers
les âges anticipés on prend en compte la
pénibilité pour ceux qui sont exposés
dans les risques différemment ce qui
concerne l'inaptitude qu'elle a aussi un
autre facteur mais différent
indépendants du monde du travail ou en
ce qui concerne l'invalidité et il nous
appartient à ce moment-là de prendre des
dispositions pour des retraites
anticipées mais ce que je voudrais bien
que l'on partage c'est que quand on
prend une disposition pour un agent
anticipé de retraite ça veut dire que
nous accordons
aux personnes concernées une retraite
plus longue que les autres on sait que
la durée moyenne des retraites c'est
aller on va dire 20 ans 22 ans sur la
voilà 20 ans c'est derrière cette durée
un rapport par rapport à votre
usure au travail c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre objectif a toujours été
d'être attentif à ce que cette durée
plus longue accordée parce que on peut
penser derrière qui a désigne notamment
des espérances de vie qui ne sont plus
courtes c'est pour ça que le dispositif
doit être non pas le plus juste possible
on y arrivera pas mais le moins injuste
possible
en ce qui concerne les maires de famille
on va l'aborder là aussi la même
stratégie nous pensons que dans un
dispositif ou un demande à tout le monde
de travailler plus faut prendre en
compte les difficultés des maires de
famille et faire en sorte qu'on arrive à
améliorer leur pension c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons plutôt choisi
ce dispositif de qu'un âge d'ouverture
avancée des droits et dans tout cela la
logique de la commission essaiera de
s'appliquer à un maximum de personnes
c'est d'ailleurs la même logique me
semble-t-il que nous aurons ce qui
concerne les régimes spéciaux pour faire
en sorte que ceux qui ont une usure
professionnelle qu'il soit dans un
régime spécial ou à côté puissent
bénéficier effectivement s'ils ont une
espérance de vie moins d'une durée plus
longue d'une durée plus longue de la
retraite mais pour des raisons de prise
en compte de la pénibilité pas pour des
raisons historiques voyez-vous c'est un
raisonnement du 20e siècle par rapport
au raisonnement du 19e siècle qui
faisait que on accordait une retraite
par anticipée c'est un droit social en
compensation d'un salaire moindre et
bien non mais nous on réfléchit plus
comme ça et les Français
doivent être assurés que nous soyons le
moins inégalitaire possible dans les
différents dispositifs de cette réforme
et c'est la raison pour laquelle me
semblait important de les rappeler en ce
qui concerne cet article 8 merci alors
avant que nous passions la discussion
des amendements monsieur le ministre
vous souhaitiez vous exprimer pour
répondre à Monsieur canevin à Monsieur
jeandais autant pour moi merci monsieur
le Président si vous me le permettez je
répondrai même peut-être à d'autres
sénateurs qui sont exprimés simplement
pour d'abord commencer par deux points
qui sont de volonté de ma part
d'apporter et pardon pour les auteurs
des corrections à des propos madame
pensez moi je vous avais ouvert cette
discussion générale sur l'article en
disant que parmi les départs d'anticipés
la pénibilité donc l'incapacité était le
facteur principal ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas vrai nous avons 42% des
assurés qui chaque année partent avant
l'âge légal général si vous motorisez
cette expression sur ces 42%, 22 partent
au titre des départs pour carrière
longue les départs anticipées pour
carrière longue 15 pour des questions
relatives à l'incapacité l'invalidité ce
sont 100000 personnes par an cela
renvoie comme la dimension rapporteur à
l'article 9 parce que j'ai eu l'occasion
je crois de le partager avec vous soit
au début de nos travaux soit la maison
des débats en commission mais je ne
trouve pas satisfaisant à la fois
humainement intellectuellement je ne
trouve pas satisfaisant qu'un assuré sur
15 peut-être un peu moins
parte pardonnez-moi un assuré sur 7
partent de manière anticipée pour des
problèmes de santé je pense que l'enjeu
que nous avons et d'avancer sur les
questions de prévention de la pénibilité
parce qu'il y a 1000 fois plus de
satisfaction et 1000 fois plus d'intérêt
à permettre par la prévention un maximum
d'assurer d'aller jusqu'à l'âge légal
quoi qu'on pense de cet âge plutôt qu'à
compenser des difficultés de santé par
un départ anticipé de deux ans je
préfère que des assurés partent au bon
âge en bonne forme plutôt de manière
anticipée en mauvaise santé et c'est
tout l'enjeu de la prévention vous avez
dit madame la sénatrice que ce
dispositif avait vocation à s'étendre et
c'est vrai que si nous ne faisons rien
si nous restons sur le dispositif de
carrière longue j'y reviendrai pour
répondre à Monsieur joélandais
si nous ne faisons rien ce dispositif à
vocation à effectivement concerné de
moins en moins de monde pour une raison
toute simple c'est que l'âge moyen
d'entrer dans la vie active tant
augmenter donc mécaniquement le nombre
de personnes ayant cotisé des trimestres
suffisammentaux pour bénéficier d'un
dispositif carrière longue avant
vocation ABC mais ce que nous
proposerons pas au Sénat et donc au
Parlement d'adopter avec notamment une
nouvelle borne d'âge vient contrecarrer
ce mouvement ensuite il y a une deuxième
inexactitude que je voulais à laquelle
je voulais apporter une correction qui a
été exprimée notamment par Madame
benbassam mais je ne sais pas si elle
est restée avec nous et qui a été
reprise pour une partie par madame la
sénatrice meunier c'est ce qui concerne
la situation du handicap nous maintenons
il n'y a pas de dégradation c'est le
premier point que je souligne nous
maintenant à 55 ans la possibilité d'un
départ anticipé pour les travailleurs
handicapés
et donc il n'y a pas de dégradation de
cette borne d'âge c'est un maintien pur
et dur et ensuite madame meunier vous
avez évoqué le fait que les critères
pourraient être plus restrictifs c'est
justement l'inverse que nous faisons
actuellement dans le cas d'un assuré qui
est né en 1972 et qui souhaitent partir
à 55 ans il faut remplir une double une
double condition avoir cotisé 118
trimestres et en avoir validé 20 de plus
60 38 nous gardons la cotisation la
durée de cotisation à 118 aujourd'hui
ces deux conditions sont cumulatives
demain la durée de cotisation est 118
sera exclusive ce qui permettra des
assurés en cotisé 118 trimestres de ne
pas avoir à se poser la question des
vins trimestres supplémentaires de
validation à obtenir pour pouvoir partir
et donc c'est une facilitation du départ
pour les travailleurs en situation de
handicap de la même manière d'ailleurs
que dans le cas des départs en
incapacité quoi qu'on pense de ses
départs et quoi que j'ai dit sur
l'utilité de la prévention
nous prévoyons dans le texte que nous
vous proposons que les travailleurs qui
ont un taux d'inaptitude un taux
d'incapacité supérieure à 20% puisse
bénéficier d'un départ anticipé comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui de manière
automatique et non pas sur avis médical
considérant que dès lors que le taux
d'incapacité supérieur à 20% on peut
considérer que la vie médicale adore
déjà été rendu et avec une ampleur et
une importance suffisamment
significative pour autoriser un départ
anticipé sans passer par un deuxième
avis médical j'en viens à
deux points sur lesquels je conclurai
pardon c'est un peu long mais cela me
permettra d'aller beaucoup plus vite sur
les très nombreux amendements et
sous-amendement de l'article d'abord le
dispositif de carrière longue monsieur
c'est à torche ayant déma interpellé
mais je crois que c'est un sujet qui
concerne et qui intéresse beaucoup de
sénateurs comme il est intéressé
beaucoup de députés quel est le
dispositif aujourd'hui il a été créé en
2003 il autorise des travailleurs des
assurés plus exactement qui ont rempli
trois conditions à partir de manière
anticipée il y a un premier dispositif
pour ceux qui ont cotisé en fonction de
leur date de naissance petite complexité
supplémentaire entre 4 et 5 trimestres
par an mais restons sur 5 pour faciliter
la démonstration cinq trimestres avant
16 ans c'est un départ anticipé autorisé
à partir de 58 ans et 5 trimestres en
menton c'est un départ autorisé deux ans
avant l'âge légal donc aujourd'hui 60
demain 62 mais il y a trois conditions
cumulatives et impératives la première
c'est d'avoir cinq trimestres cotisés
avant la borne dash tels que définie par
la loi la deuxième c'est d'avoir atteint
l'âge d'ouverture des droits spécifiques
fixés en relation avec chacune des
bornes d'âge et la troisième c'est
d'avoir une durée de cotisation requise
qui soit intégralement cotisée sans
tenir compte des trimestres validés et
j'ajoute aussi que dans l'état du droit
pour le dispositif moins de saison il
s'agit d'une durée de cotisation égale à
la durée de cotisation exigée pour tous
les assurés plus 8 trimestre soit deux
ans donc en l'occurrence 44 ans et
demain 45 ans
puisque aujourd'hui si vous faites
valoir le droit à un départ anticipé
parce que vous avez atteint les 60 ans
et que vous avez cotisé 5 trimestres
dans 20 ans il va falloir démontrer que
vous avez cotisé 168 trimestres et il se
peut que vous ayez fait un service
militaire qui vous est droit à 4
trimestres valider mais non cotisés il
ne compte pas une femme qui commence à
travailler avant 20 ans qui a un moment
de sa vie
prend bénéficie c'est logique à cet
endroit d'un congé parental ce sont les
trimestres validés qui ne comptent pas
dans la durée cotisée nous allons
changer aussi si je prends ces deux
exemples c'est pour souligner que en
l'état du droit et je vais venir sur ce
que nous proposons de changer ainsi que
sur les coûts vous avez demandé en
l'état du droit le dispositif de départ
anticipé pour ceux qui ont travaillé
avant 20 ans qui se traduit dans la loi
par une bonification de deux ans la
bonification effective constatée pour
qu'on tienne compte des trois critères
cumulatifs c'est neuf mois
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est une
machine à déception c'est parce que
quand on affiche dans la loi un
dispositif de départ anticipé à deux ans
les conditions cumulatives que j'ai
exposées font que l'on vient à 9 mois je
viens à votre question
je le dis parce que c'est comme ça que
le système est construit et ce qui a
détermine les réponses que j'apporte sur
les questions de couple vous avez évoqué
que proposons-nous avec cette loi nous
proposons deux choses d'abord la
première c'est de créer une nouvelle
borne d'âge à 18 ans pour faire en sorte
que ceux qui ont cinq trimestres avant
18 ans puissent bénéficier non pas de
deux ans des parents de CP mais de 4 ans
et nous allons vous proposer nous allons
soutenir plutôt nous allons proposer à
l'assemblée nous allons soutenir ici un
amendement permettant de créer une borne
d'âge avec une bonification d'un nom
pour ceux qui ont 5 trimestres avant 21
ans on peut convenir que quand on arrive
à 21 ans on peut s'interroger sur le
fait d'avoir commencé très jeune ou
moins jeune
c'est ce que nous vous proposons vous
m'avez posé des questions sur le coup
des amendements que vous avez retiré
pour les raisons que vous avez évoquées
il y a plusieurs coups que je peux
partager avec vous s'il s'agit de dire
comme ça a été évoquait l'Assemblée
nationale à la fin des débats le
vendredi s'il s'agit de dire que les
deux conditions cumulatives que j'ai les
trois conditions cumulatives que j'ai
évoquées serait modifié pour dire que le
départ serait autorisé dès lors que
l'âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits
les 5 trimestres cotisés sont remplies
mais qui n'est pas exigé d'avoir plus de
43 années au moment de l'atteinte de
l'âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits
ça coûte 300 à 350 millions d'euros s'il
s'agit de dire que tout assuré qui a
commencé à travailler un jour avant ses
21 ans ne se voit pas appliquer
un âge d'ouverture des droits mais
simplement une durée de cotisation à 43
ans cela coûte entre 7 et 10 milliards
d'euros c'est dans combien de abordable
et s'il s'agit de dire que
tout assuré qui a commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans se voit absolument garantie
indépendamment de toute tâche spécifique
d'ouverture des droits et uniquement par
le maintien de la condition du nombre de
trimestres avant tel ou tel âge de
départ cela coûte 1 milliard 7
ce sont des chiffres qui sont
conséquents qui sont extrêmement
importants et qui viennent contredire
l'objectif d'équilibre que nous pouvons
les uns et les autres partager
nous avons cette difficulté là je
souligne parce que nous avons cet
objectif d'équilibre du système je
termine d'un mot sur les carrières
longues avant de dire un mot de
l'amendement monsieur Savin
un mot sur les carrières longues puisque
vous avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur
l'idée que finalement nous pourrions
garantir que les 43 années de cotisation
serait une forme de plafond et et que ce
sera un plafond auquel au-delà duquel on
ne demandera la personne d'aller je ne
peux qu'être en opposition avec cette
proposition car la philosophie même je
sais pas si le terme est le plus
approprié mais en tout cas les principes
même de construction de notre système de
retraite depuis qu'il existe sont de
cumuler deux conditions pour le départ
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et je le
répète nous l'avons évoqué à l'article 7
le fait d'avoir un âge légal d'ouverture
des droits est une protection contre les
machines à des cotes que sont les
systèmes fondés uniquement sur la durée
de cotisation et une durée de
cotisations sauf que la durée de
cotisation dans le système tel qu'il est
pensé n'a toujours a toujours été vu
comme un plancher jamais comme un
plafond je prends deux exemples pour
illustrer premier exemple il est
extrêmement simple d'une certaine
manière
c'est que chaque année sur les 800 000
départs à la retraite nous avons 180 000
assurés qui partent avec plus de
trimestres qu'il n'en faut c'est un fait
constaté parce que justement c'est un
plancher et nous avons évoqué à
l'article 7 nous avons même adopté vous
avez adopté pardon un certain nombre
d'amendements qu'on se demande les
enseignants du primaire qui démontrent
qui était facile de passer le nombre de
trimestres requis et le deuxième exemple
c'est pour partager avec vous les
progrès qui ont été faits depuis une
vingtaine d'années avant 2003 avant la
création des dispositifs de carrière
longue l'âge de départ était à 60 ans et
la durée de cotisations requise à 37 ans
et demi si vous faisiez des études vous
aviez une licence une maîtrise peu
importe et que vous commencez votre
carrière à 22 ans et demi vous
travaillez 37 ans et demi vous prenez
votre traite à 60 ans à taux plein et
votre camarade de classe de primaire ou
de collège ou de primaire plutôt pouvez
commencer à travailler dans une usine à
15 ans et devoir travailler 45 ans pour
avoir une retraite à taux plein au même
âge que vous à 60 ans ça faisait un
écart de 8 ans et parfois plus pour ceux
qui commencent à travailler très tôt
avec les carrières longues cet écart
c'est progressivement réduit et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un système
qui fait que pour ce qui est la durée de
cotisation requise et à la fois pour
atteindre ce plancher et pour atteindre
les âges d'ouverture des droits les
quarts et de 1 2 ans et avec ce que nous
vous proposons notamment sur les
carrières longues avant 18 ans et les
carrières longues avant 21 ans ça sera
un an et même moins d'un an en fonction
de votre date de naissance et du moment
auquel vous rentrez dans la vie active
vous avez aussi évoqué cela a été dit
par Madame A pour cepoli je crois que en
fonction de l'âge auquel on commence on
pourrait être amené à travailler 43 ou
44 ans la réalité est plus complexe ce
raisonnement et celui que vous avez eu
madame la sénatrice ni juste que dans le
cas où les assurés commencent à
travailler le jour de leur anniversaire
on peut commencer à travailler à 16 ans
mais bien souvent c'est 16 ans et 3 mois
bien souvent c'est 16 ans et demi et
dans ce cas-là ce n'est pas 44 ans qui
sont réalisés pour atteindre l'âge
d'ouverture des droits c'est 43 ans et 3
mois 43 ans et 6 mois 43 ans et 9 mois
et donc évidemment dire qu'il y aurait
un plafond au-delà duquel on n'irait pas
ça n'existe pas parce qu'on ne peut pas
construire une société dans laquelle on
garantit à tous les individus de ne pas
travailler un jour de plus que les
autres ça ne marche tout simplement pas
avec notre système de protection sociale
je termine par un dernier point monsieur
le Président pour dire un mot de
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary adopté
par la commission des affaires sociales
et dont nous avons beaucoup discuté avec
les uns et les autres j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire que je reconnaissais là
l'initiative du président Retailleau
c'est un point qui est important parce
que ça concerne la question des femmes
des mères mais en réalité ce qui la
concerne la question des droits
familiaux que propose cet amendement et
qui nous paraît dans le bon sens et il
propose de tenir compte du fait que
progressivement l'augmentation de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits et ça n'est pas
lié à ce ciel à cette seule réforme
c'est un mouvement beaucoup plus long
cette augmentation d'ouverture des
droits c'est se traduit peut se traduire
pardon par le sentiment ou la
constatation qu'il est trimestres à
quiothique de la maternité ou
l'éducation des enfants deviennent moins
utiles
en fait c'est un mouvement de société
que nous connaissons la carrière des
femmes le taux d'emploi des femmes
progressent et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle et de ce que les droits
familiaux ont été créés lorsque les
trimestre de maternité ont été créés
dans les années 60 et 70 ils étaient
pensés pour compenser des trimestres
pendant lesquels les femmes ne pouvaient
tout simplement pas cotiser parce que le
congé maternité n'était pas suffisamment
élevé pour
transformer le trimestre entre mes
cotiser et parce qu'il y avait une
interruption d'activité aujourd'hui
c'est une bonne nouvelle plus souvent il
y a toujours évidemment plein de
difficultés mais que souvent une femme
qui accouche peut valider le trimestre
par le congé maternité et reprendre son
activité pour valider de trimestres et
c'est trimestre de compensation
deviennent des trimestres de majoration
et cet endroit qui est comme cela qui
existe et on ne le remet pas en cause
par contre qu'une femme qui a une
carrière complète ou quasiment complète
un an près qui arrive à l'âge
d'ouverture des droits peut si elle a
travaillé 42 ans sans interruption
particulière peut considérer que ces
trimestres sont ainsi perdus ou en tout
cas moi utile la réalité c'est que la
situation varie beaucoup selon les
femmes les femmes sont toujours plus
exposées que les hommes aux carrière
hachées et donc pour beaucoup d'entre
elles le fait d'avoir des trimestres de
majorations évite d'avoir des décote
parce que ça permet d'avoir les 42 ou
les 43 ans requis et puis pour d'autres
c'est moins utile l'amendement qui est
proposé qui est adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales elle le mérite de
conserver les deux intérêts on maintient
les majorations de droits les majoration
de durée d'affiliation pour les femmes
pour les parents puisque je rappelle
qu'il y a des trimestes d'éducation qui
peuvent être réparties entre les parents
au sein du couple donc nous maintenons
ces droits là pour celles le plus
souvent
qui ont une carrière incomplète cela
permet d'éviter la décote ou de la
limiter ce qui est une très bonne chose
et pour celle le plus souvent mais
parfois ce mais c'est très très
majoritairement celle qui est arrivé un
an avant l'âge d'ouverture des droits à
63 ans ont une durée d'affiliation
requise atteinte par ces trimestres de
majoration alors qu'il leur reste un an
à travailler le système de surcotte
permet d'apporter une compensation et la
compensation paraît juste pour une seule
raison pour une raison particulière
c'est que si une femme a pu travailler
toute sa carrière et faire une carrière
complète malgré le fait d'avoir des
enfants c'est la démonstration que sa
maternité ces maternité n'ont pas été
inconciliables avec sa carrière
professionnelle par contre ce que l'on
sait c'est que si cette conciliation est
plus facile ou moins difficile
aujourd'hui la maternité reste un frein
à la promotion et si c'est un frein à la
promotion sans être un empêchement de
travailler le fait de majorer la pension
et peut-être la plus juste des
compensations à apporter au moment de la
retraite et c'est
ou adoption monsieur le Président vous
avez raison c'est la parentalité d'une
certaine manière pour être plus large
que la seule maternité ou la seule
paternité et donc ça permet de conserver
ces deux aspects c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement sera favorable
à cet amendement
alors la présidente de la Commission a
demandé la parole pour le débat sur les
amendements
président et en application de
l'articante 6 bisaline à deux du
règlement la Commission propose de Sénat
de disjointe l'amendement
2127 du rapporteur des rapporteurs de la
discussion commune et en application de
l'article 44 à 6 de règlement la
Commission demande la priorité d'examens
de vote sur cet amendement
donc sur la priorité
le gouvernement de si oppose pas
comme pour les comme pour les décisions
la commission prise précédemment le
Gouvernement s'en remet la commission
alors la priorité est ordonnée
et alors en vertu de la clique 46 bis
alinéa 2 du règlement
la Commission demande l'examen séparé de
l'amendement de 1127 de la commission
avant l'article 8 enfin au début de la
discussion des articles 8 est-ce qu'il y
a un orateur qui s'y oppose
madame Rossignol madame la Présidente
rossignol
je ne répondrai pas la question est-ce
qu'il y en orateur qui s'oppose je
voudrais juste parce que quand même ça
demande qu'on serait adapte même si on
est très souple et très flexible
est-ce que vous allez encore nous sortir
l'article 38 dans 30 secondes ou est-ce
que sur cette terre et sur cette
amendement qui est important où on peut
en vraiment en bonne intelligence
considérée qu'il y aura des choses à
dire pour beaucoup d'entre nous est-ce
qu'on peut cesser le temps du débat au
moins sans abonnement et tous ceux qui
ne connaissent et qui savent qu'elles
sont mes sujets peuvent comprendre que
ma question est absolument sincère
oui madame la Présidente pour expliquer
votre proposition
bon écoutez je veux bien qu'on discute
ainsi mais bon faut quand même pas parce
que moi une expression un peu populaire
nous prendre pour des lapins de six
semaines
on prend pour des lapins de 6 semaines
vous vous poussez des cris d'or frais
parce que en effet
l'adoption de l'amendement ferait tomber
les amendements de suppression mais vous
avez déposé 300 sous amendements ce qui
fait qu'on va discuter
lui de l'article de
de l'amendement de l'amendement non
attendez regardez les sous amendements
regardez les sous amendements
300 c'est pas votre question mais c'est
ma réponse 300
300 sous amendements 300 sous
amendements dont nous allons discuter
tout l'après-midi le début de la soirée
haute alors me dites pas qu'on vous
prive de discussions sur l'amendement de
surcote des femmes de René Paul Savary
parce que là un moment bon je viens tout
entendre mais ça va
alors
[Applaudissements]
nous devons nous prononcer sur cette
demande de prior d'examen séparés
monsieur le Président canner
oui monsieur le Président je crois que
vous accepterez quand même que la
décision portée par Madame de roche
modifie considérablement lors de
lancement de nos travaux
mais oui c'est comme ça
venez pas nous reprocher d'essayer de
parler alors que vous vous êtes en train
de nous empêcher de parler donc monsieur
le Président je sollicite de votre
bienveillance pour nous permettre de
nous réorganiser une suspension de
séance de 10 minutes
madame la Présidente considérez-vous que
c'est utile pour le déroulement des
travaux
vous avez 300 sous amendements vous
aurez tout le temps de parler sur ces
300 sous amendement sans qu'il y ait une
suspension de séance pour voir si en
effet c'est compliqué et si on ne peut
pas parler avec 300 sous amendements moi
je ne suis pas favorable mais ce n'est
pas moi qui décide
monsieur le Président gonta pour me
rappeler le règlement
sur l'article 44 bis moi je voudrais
juste remettre peut-être les choses les
choses à l'endroit parce que oui non
mais on est sur on est sur des sujets on
est sur des sujets particulièrement
importants que ça soit l'article 7
maintenant ce qu'on va aborder sur
l'article 8 on nous accuse enfin c'est
votre petit jeu depuis un petit un petit
moment oui sur de l'obstruction sur de
l'obstruction si je peux parler
sur de l'obstruction il me semble qu'on
a commencé le texte on avait 3500 3000
3600 amendements global que vous vous en
avez un peu plus de 1000 où est
l'obstruction on a fait notre travail
d'amendement moi ça me choque pas
absolument pas que sur un sujet comme
celui-là que l'ensemble des sénatrices
et des sénateurs est déposer un
amendement et je suis même étonné qui
est pas à 348 amendements parce que on
représente chacun nos territoires et je
peux vous dire que dans nos territoires
l'ensemble de ces spécificités
l'ensemble de ces retours sur la vie des
gens le fait de passer sur l'article 7
de 62 à 64 ans moi je l'entends sur mon
territoire et j'ai envie de m'exprimer
parce qu'on me demande de m'exprimer et
c'est ça la réalité du Parlement c'est
cette réalité là et c'est cette réalité
là que vous nier dangereusement
dangereusement parce que à travers ça
vous nier la démocratie alors s'il vous
plaît n'inversez pas les choses
n'inverse pas les choses
un article 38 l'article 42 qui fait que
effectivement quand on remet en question
quand on vous redéposez un amendement
qui est réécrit mais qui veut dire la
même chose quel autre possibilité nous
avons que deux sous amendes donc
n'inversez pas les choses on a eu des
débats intéressants serein jusque
l'article 7 pourquoi vous ne souhaitez
pas poursuivre sur cette voie là on est
à la moitié du texte on est à l'article
8 il nous reste encore du temps des
bâtons et des bâtons de l'ensemble des
amendements merci
je dois consulter le Sénat sur cette
demande étant entendu que si l'examen
séparé est adopté par le Sénat nous
ferons une suspension qui permettra aux
collègues de revoir l'ordre de
préparation de leurs interventions
madame Gréoux vous souhaitez vous
exprimer avant ce vote simple sur la
procédure je vais m'exprimer également
Président vous
la procédure mais pour répondre aux
nombreuses observations sur le fait que
nous faisons de l'obstruction sur ce
projet de réforme je voulais simplement
vous dire que le groupe communiste que
nous sommes malgré qu'ils ne soient pas
grand en taille il travaille il
travaille dur et en toute sérénité ne
croyez pas que le nombre d'amendements
sert à faire de l'obstruction vous serez
dans l'erreur nous avons déjà prouvé
notre efficacité je vais vous prendre un
exemple dernier en date je vous rappelle
que la commission d'enquête sur
l'influence des cabinets conseils donc
vous connaissez les résultats connus et
reconnus sont de notre initiative alors
permettez-nous de donner nos points de
vue sur les effets collatéraux que cette
réforme va engendrer nous défendons ce
que nous trouvons injuste et c'est pour
c'est pour cela que nous sommes élus
merci
monsieur kerouche sur la demande de
scrutin séparés
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes frontalement
structurellement en opposition sur ce
sur ce texte frontalement il y a une
division forte entre la droite et la
majorité gouvernementale qui
n'appartiennent plus maintenant qu'à un
même groupe et les bandes et les bandes
et les bancs de la gauche mais
je m'étonne que vous vous étonniez vous
le mettez en place au sein de cette
Assemblée l'ensemble des procédures de
parlementarisme rationalisé que vous
pouvez mettre en place pour faire en
sorte de réduire notre temps de parole
et vous vous étonnez et vous vous
étonnez et vous vous étonnez donc que
nous réagissions par tous les par tous
les moyens disponibles c'est
relativement c'est relativement étonnant
nous prendrons et nous mettrons en œuvre
tous les moyens dont nous disposons
parce que vous avez choisi parce que
vous avez choisi du tri d'utiliser la
brut alité c'est votre choix c'est votre
choix initial et tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure ou hier le
président Marseille a dit que les
mouches avaient changé d'âne je vous
rappelle cette citation je vous rappelle
cette citation latine azinos azzinum
fricate l'âne fréquente l'âne
améliocrité médiocrité ennemie
[Applaudissements]
je consulte le Sénat qui est pour
l'examen séparé après madame après
qui est pour l'examen séparé
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'examen séparé est
adopté nous suspendons jusqu'à 12h30
12h30
seront victimes ces personnes avec la
réforme du gouvernement et la droite
aussi qui souhaitent et bien adoucir les
mesures prévues par le gouvernement
notamment en ce qui concerne les maires
de famille faut le savoir aussi que le
gouvernement a déjà procédé à quelques
concessions lors du passage du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment face aux
demandes du groupe LR du député Aurélien
Pradier le député LR Aurélien Pradier
avoir jusqu'où est prêt à aller le
gouvernement aujourd'hui le Sénat qui
s'est donc emparé de cette question des
carrières longues cette question qui a
et bien suscité beaucoup d'oppositions
qui suscitent en tout cas beaucoup
d'incompréhension chez un certain nombre
de Français Alex
effectivement Steve le Sénat qui donc
commence l'examen de cet article 8 sur
les carrières longues un examen qui
commence de manière assez tendue après
que ce matin elle a le droit de
sénatoriale et a décidé de reporter le
débat sur l'amendement de Bruno
Retailleau qui voulait accélérer la
suppression des régimes spéciaux qui est
prévu par cette réforme des retraites
alors aujourd'hui les débats des
sénateurs devraient être consacrés à
cette article 8 sur les carrières
longues qui effectivement a fait l'objet
de tractation entre le gouvernement et
les républicains dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites notamment dans le
débat sur l'Assemblée nationale et
Isabelle borne la première ministre qui
a concédé des améliorations de ce
dispositif pour satisfaire les
républicains et notamment Aurélien
Pradier le député avec et bien une
nouvelle borne d'âge qui va être
introduite dans ce dispositif carrière
longue on le rappelle à la base cette
réforme de retraite introduit trois
bornes d'âge pour des départs anticipés
pour ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt avancez-en avant 18 ans et avant 20
ans et la première ministre a prévu et
bien une nouvelle borne d'âge avant 21
ans cette nouvelle borne sera défendue
par un amendement du sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle Xavier